[Musique]
geert jan bleecker est infirmier et fier
de l'être il travaille pour aller rim us
une des entreprises privées auxquelles
le gouvernement néerlandais fait appel
pour fournir les soins à domicile aux
personnes âgées
des personnes parfois très malade comme
l'aisne vermaas 90 ans qui souffre
d'insuffisance cardiaque et respiratoire
et qui vit seule dans sa petite maison
et kendrick
monsieur faire masse est considéré comme
un patient en fin de vie les infirmiers
lui rende visite deux fois par jour et
il peut communiquer avec eux en tout
temps en cas d'urgence
la petite équipe de geert jan qui compte
quatre infirmières prend soin d'une
cinquantaine de patients atteints
de
certains sont vus plusieurs fois par
jour comme cette dame atteinte de
plusieurs maladies et qui jusqu'à tout
récemment cohabiter avec un mari atteint
de démence
son mari est hospitalisée elle reçoit de
l'aide psychologique
une fois par semaine en plus des visites
quotidiennes des infirmiers
witch et
les infirmiers sont en contact avec un
médecin qui intervient au besoin
vous l'anglais
la docteure fait lohan ne sera aussi
parfois chez les patients âgés mais elle
compte beaucoup sur le personnel
infirmier pour évaluer les besoins et
faire les suivis requis
le suivi des patients peut se faire par
visioconférence avec cette femme par
exemple qui souffre d'un début de
démence et qui vit seule l'équipe
d'infirmiers compte aussi sur sa fille
qui habite à proximité du plan de france
en barres nez
aleri mus gère un centre de jour où les
patients qui vivent seuls à la maison
peuvent socialiser une ou deux fois par
semaine
[Musique]
tous les soins à la maison et toutes les
activités sociales pour les personnes
âgées sont financés par l'état
néerlandais et par un régime d'assurance
parmi les plus généreux au monde il y à
presque deux fois moins de lits pour
aînés dans les centres de soins publics
aux pays bas comparativement au québec
le maintien à domicile permet
d'économiser des sommes considérables
mais c'est d'abord une question de
philosophie de mentalité qui explique
cette différence nous 17 chercheurs
monsieur sanders je ne pourrais pas
vivre à la maison s'ils étaient seuls il
y presque totalement dépendant de sa
femme qui à 75 ans se demande combien de
temps il pourra encore tenir ici c'est
bien qu'on peut rester dans la maison
c'est pas facile de trouver une place
quand on a besoin de maisons pour les
handicapés ou dess de dieu personne
parce que là ce sont plein plein plein
et ça c'est pourquoi on veut qu est le
plus longtemps dans la maison avec
l'évêque comme maintenant
c'est un peu l'envers de la médaille
l'état néerlandais manquent de place
pour accueillir les personnes qui ne
sont plus autonomes il faut un peu plus
de centres de soins oui mais surtout
plus d'infirmières sur le terrain nous
dit ce médecin et toi rihanna est là
by her
in amenas
les pays bas sont eux aussi aux prises
avec un manque criant de personnel
infirmier si on construisait plus de
centres on manquerait de personnel pour
les faire fonctionner la solution réside
donc dans une approche communautaire
selon cette professeure
d'études conseille ainsi de
ouattara mais tout comme
[Musique]
les
prix
[Musique]